what is up there reject nation greg and
john here today
we're gonna react to something a little
bit different
for our taste buds today gotta give a
little bit of a backstory here
as we've been you know covering some
more scary videos again i was looking
for some like new kinds of videos to do
and then someone recommended the channel
sir spooks doing my usual like let me
just see what they're all about i came
across a video
that he did recently called this video
will give you nightmares
and it was basically about this old
youtube channel called the paranormal
paranoids so
it's exactly what it sounds like all
right
very old-school stuff from years ago and
it was this like group of
you know paranormal spooky investigators
it was
mainly led by this one girl named um
riley
so basically this channel was like doing
all these videos they're really
committed to it and then they just
sort of vanished one day and there's
this youtube channel called just the
paranoid here's what the description box
of the channel
is a place for all the video evidence i
have collected on the amateur ghost
hunting youtube channel the paranormal
paranoids
and their members riley david laura and
peter their channel and website was
deleted and as far as i can tell
no one has heard from this group since
around 2008 comments on any of the
videos if you have more information on
what might have happened to them
apparently this super creepy video after
getting involved in conversations with
people about it has
like surfaced and it supposedly is like
the last video about
riley i don't know so i know it's a lot
of backstory i'm giving you guys here
but i just thought it was really
fascinating
and uh i know it's very different than
like a list video or something
so no one knows what happened to these
guys hopefully we don't befall the
savings
hopefully we don't get cursed watching i
mean their videos are creepy very old
old-school stuff like that this is like
the annals of youtube yeah
so let's see what's in store
[Music]
i'm not safe
there's eyes on me
i'm so scared
what's up
[Applause]
great
not like their other videos holy crap
what the hell
[Music]
uh
oh
my nipples are so hard
[Laughter]
what
uh
oh
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is going on it's like
every
dog a coyote near stairs
freaking out oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
all i hear is that you're ringing from
my tinnitus
[Laughter]
yeah yeah that's all that was
[Laughter]
what the hell that was that was jarring
oh boy i'm so taken aback by that
i don't really know what to
i don't really know what to make of that
because i don't either
it's it's so different than if you go to
jess the paranoid channel and you go
through their videos from like 10 years
ago
it's not like this they're like dv chem
vlogs
exactly like hanging out and going to
paranormal places and you know they're
coming around yes it's how greg and john
would still make videos
today if we were vlogging we would be
goofing off in the paranormal place and
not really capturing ghosts
so as someone who's been diving into
this i find it very creepy and i find it
very unsettling because
i've been here for like like a week
for like a week going damn what happened
to these guys
just that alone was scary to me and
unsettling like ghosts under maybe they
found something real cause i do believe
in that kind of stuff right and then i
watch this video
and yeah they were an old school youtube
channel no one knows what happened and
then this video suddenly surfaces
they have this video here and i'm like
wait though
how exactly well how'd this video get
here
how to get delivered there's some creepy
spooky stuff happening here
but it also looks like there was someone
if this is real
here's what i've been believing is real
this whole time wannabe ghost hunters
not successful ghost hunters
they're pretty cheesy ass videos and
then these the people vanished i don't
know what happened to them my impression
was maybe they tried going somewhere
and to investigate it and something went
wrong it could have been an accident or
whatever i don't know and then this
comes out
suddenly and i'm like wait a minute is
this
now i'm questioning everything i thought
was real once you wish things like their
other videos
are definitely real not not saying like
they really found ghosts they're
authentic in the sense that they're
really trying to go out and find
something yeah
yeah this comes out
and so it just has me a little skeptical
i guess i can see why i mean any any
paranormal video
you find on the internet i feel like you
have to approach first and foremost with
skepticism just because you know like
there's
a million ways to do camera trickery but
what started to tickle my brains about
this is the fact that
it feels very paranormal and yet it also
feels just like a stuffed film of of
someone being kidnapped or something
that's what i mean tormented
like was the guy who like did it i'm
assuming god did the guy who did it
the guy at the window yeah that's what
it appears like to me like okay so was
it not a
ghost thing but then who would who like
who found this
and if it was a guy wouldn't he like
destroy the camera you know
i guess yeah i mean if that if that was
the guy who did it and they were
concerned i mean if it was me i would
have looked in the open doorway myself
so to have this video appear
let's face it we got to be real here
that feels a little bit
fabricated it feels a little bit staged
right it's impressive like even if we're
talking
fabricated river talking not real it
feels
like it's really well done like it's
really cool and def that you can't 100
percent be like
definitely you know like a part of your
brain still like oh no
yeah i like the editing and i'll be like
yeah that's some impressive
sound design we got right there you know
what a well-timed glitch
to really catch me off guard so like
this video got sent our way
people were freaked out by it because
this is the first
supposed evidence of what happened to
them see here's the thing i'm like what
would the hoax be
how could you just suddenly get a this
this hoax going like is it just for the
1.45 that
like less than two thousand subscribers
paranormal paranoids were a thing once
over a decade like there's a random
channel of just the paranoia just
like i'm gonna go all out here and make
these old-school videos and get this
cast together i'm gonna give these two
people the ride of their lives
so when i think about the intent i go i
don't know
why it would be fake other than the fact
that i'm looking at the video there are
things about it
but then that's my problem that's my
freaking problem guys that's always my
problem
i believe in this [ __ ] but then the
second something real is presented in me
i go let me just crisscross everything
here yeah just uh let me get my white
board out
let me over and put on my skeptic hat i
believe in god until something
miraculous happens and i'm like what
kind
of usa fraud situation am i saying
you're a toaster in jesus's image i mean
that's the problem yeah is anytime
you're opposed with a paranormal thing
that could
be real then immediately you just start
looking for every way in which it's
probably not real and you're always
gonna find it again i keep coming back
to that weird grounded element and
that's the uncanny valley for me as i'm
like
too grounded it's too good at some point
i'm like yeah show me a door that moves
on its own
or something that i can't explain well
usually when i watch these videos
it's like some subtle stuff is happening
yeah and sometimes when it goes big it's
not
too big like a a chair flies across the
room
or something knocks down off the shelf
or or demons if you're walking upside
down you know
all the furniture is certainly on the
scene yeah but no it's like one big
thing or something like that
or one thing but there was so much
happening here i don't see any trickery
of the camera
it's one shot like i couldn't tell other
than that little glitch i couldn't tell
of any editing gimmicks
yeah the magic of dv tapes but who would
upload this
like who who who would keep this the
equipment to rip off a dv tape and
upload it now
exactly he's got that specialty interest
it's scary though it is creepy as hell
it is creepiest i'm gonna keep following
this but guys you should check out just
the paranoia's channel so you see what i
mean so you know what i've been going
through the past week
yeah because then you'll be here just
sitting here nitpicking with us going
what is real and what is just
it's well produced horror here's the
thing it's very easy
for you guys to probably watch this and
go
that's fake i don't believe it it's well
done but i don't believe it but when you
go through their other stuff and you
learn
like who these guys were 10 years ago
and you're looking at their your footage
of stuff there's got to be some truth to
this
at minimum this feels a bit candid yeah
or they just planned the greatest jokes
of all time
they went off they went away to film
school yeah this is
what i mean she's de-aged yeah
they got the best effects they're the
people there radio silence
12 years ago they were failing and
they're like let's wait till youtube
gets bigger and the quality gets better
and then we'll resurface again it's such
a good force they did their
um uh their boyhood here with it
but yeah boyhood meets paranormal
activity is the best way to
i can think of what the paranormal i
thought of that
geniuses i don't know it's creepy it's
creepy-ass stuff for sure
anyway guys what do you think leave your
thoughts down below
and uh yeah we'll catch you guys
i'll do a list video next time